Mass Effect 1 and...
1 and 2 is...
A game...
Are games that I really, really love.
[Mozart's Requiem plays in the background] They were so... Immersive.
[Mozart's Requiem plays in the background] Being part of the...
[Mozart's Requiem plays in the background] Spaceship...
[Mozart's Requiem plays in the background] Going far out in the galaxy...
[Mozart's Requiem plays in the background] Where? Where did it go wrong?
[Music: "Requiem Mass in D minor (K. 626)" by Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart]
[Requiem Mass in D minor (K. 626) by Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart]
Th- The new Mass Effect: Andromeda is coming out.
And it's uh.. It's looking pretty interesting.
*laughing*
What happened? What happened? Where did it go wrong?
These are the template faces for any female characters.
We have... What the fuck? And...
What the fuck? We also have what the shit?
And... What the fuck? And... What the fuck?
And... What the shit?
What... Okay. Listen. I get it.
They look like normal people,
but take Final Fantasy, just an example. Look at-
Just compare their facial expression. Alright?
She's making- She's even making a face.
It looks... It looks... Attractive. It looks interesting.
What the actual fuck? Would you call this then?
2017! The peak... of video gaming...
How much is- How much does this game cost?
40 million.
40 million dollars.
40, million.
Where did those 40 million dollars go? I don't-
*laughing*
It gets better... It gets better.
So th- the main character, in this uh... In this one.
Her face is uh...
What should we call it? Uh... Special.
It's uh... It's- *laughter*
She makes uh... She makes interesting, you know.
She's an interesting character.
It really feels like a human character that I can relate to.
Finally! Thank you Bioware!
Now this... This is what I always wanted in gaming.
*laughter*
Jesus.
My god.
What happened?
Bioware, I wanna know. I wanna know what happened.
2008.
2017! *laughter*
Now those are just the facial expressions.
Let's take a look at some of the... Pixar-worthy animations.
This face.
What are you...
What is happening there?
She must be constipated.
Maybe... Maybe they haven't solved that in... in the future, in space.
Constipation has always and will always
be a problem for humanity.
It's ironic because the faces she makes it's the
same faces I make when I see these animations.
This one, I love.
*laughter*
What is happening?
*laughing* Oh.
Hell yeah. It's terrifying, it's fucking terrifying.
I used to love Mass Effect
The best-- one of my favourite games ever.
Was so good.
I have-I have like 200 hours in those games
What is that face Bioware?
what is she-look at her eyes
I think she just realised that she's a shitty animation.
What is he doing?
He's beginning to believe
(dramatic music)
It's too beautiful. This is too beautiful
It makes me happy
I can't-honestly this makes me-I wasn't-
Honestly, I wasn't sure if I was going to buy the game
But now 100%
I am going to play the game
Look at that
Flawless movement
It feels like I'm there
And the action
So intense
So real it almost feels like I'm throwing the punch myself
Look at this, Danny
(Punch sound effect)
This isn't Hollywood you don't have to fake punches
You can actually punch them, Bioware.
I dunno if you were aware of this
But um
You can actually punch-- cause they're not real
they're not real so you can punch them
I think it's okay no one's going to be
offended at least you know I can't speak
for everyone but I-
I think at least
I think at least.
Uh-- the flawless
The flawless walking animations
This is how humans walk
This is how we should be walking
If you are walking other ways,
You're walking wrong
Best game
The reviews aren't out for this game yet but I can
imagine it's going to be a
a metascore of 99 on Metacritic
Taking over Zelda
That lip movement
This is how
you talk don't you know I imagine that
they were inspired by Zelda CGI when
they made this-- Zelda CGI which of
course has some of the finest animation of all time.
[Silence]
They modeled a gun... backwards.
Is this real? I can't tell. Did they, they model a
gun backwards? I'm sorry but how is that
possible? I can't...
Can you imagine-- can you imagine if someone shows up to you and be like, "Hey...
give me your fucking money."
You know, some people have been
criticizing Mass Effect Andromeda for, uh,
selling out essentially, you know, li--
just living off the title and not making
a great game. Disgusting, it's disgusting
to even make these claims, because that
has never been done before ever in
gaming, all right? Call of Duty gets
better every single year. Dragon Age, one of my
favourite games, got better by every title.
Sonic is like the finest whiskey, the
more it ages, the better that it gets.
Actually that's, that's true.
[Music]
Halo, first one was garbage, the, the latest
one was so good, so much better than the
other ones. Bungie didn't know what they
were doing with Halo, definitely not.
[Music]
And the love scenes...
*sigh*
[Music]
always so beautiful, they speak to my
very soul. I wish I didn't have a
girlfriend so I can watch these. I-I with full intent.
Yes... yes... *laughter* what is that face?
That's how you show emotion. This is
why video games needs to be nominated as
Oscars because there's so much art and
expression and drama in, in every single frame.
40 million huh? Can't wait to play it.
Finally, a character I can relate to...
finally a game with animation so good...
it makes you feel like you're there...
finally a studio that shows the passion in video gaming
[Dramatic music]
You should have-- you should, you should
have killed the game just kill it with,
you should have killed it with Shepherd.
God damn I miss Commander Shepard. Let it just be clear, uh, the game might still be
great, you know, these are-- these are just
flaws based on you know restricted
footage so I'm sure like over the
hundred hours of gameplay there's not
going to be any more flaws
exlitalice made a comparison of the two th--
ten years, was it ten years Mass Effect came out?
Look at this... Look at the facial expression and the difference
oh my God
"Bruh look at this dude wait till you see *laughter* no no no no
*laughter*
look at the top of this head
look at his lips"
*laughter*
This is why I don't play games anymore.
Thank you Bioware. God bless you
*Mass Effect game